nächster redner für die alte fraktion
steffen kothe
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren
mein vorredner helfe ich hatte da was
falsch verstanden die afd macht politik
für deutschland und es liegt im
deutschen interesse
wenn es sinnvolle projekte mit russland
gibt das hat überhaupt nichts mit der
russischen politik zu tun
das will ich an dieser stelle jetzt noch
mal klar stellen und diese aktuelle
stunde jetzt hier beantragt haben die
erfreut mich ja insoweit als dass wir
von der afg ist die erkenntnis wirklich
mitnehmen dass hier fast alle im haus am
gleichen strang ziehen nämlich nord
stream zwei zu ermöglichen nordsee in
zwei zu ermöglichen es gibt glaube ich
herr trittin korrigieren sie mich bitte
wenn ich die daher falsch verstanden
habe ich habe es so verstanden dass die
grünen also nord stream zwar am liebsten
beerdigen würden und trotzdem freut uns
dass wir diese aktuelle stunde haben um
das nochmal klar gestellt zu haben dass
das hier im hohen hause nahezu konsens
ist dass wir nur zwischen zwei
unterstützen
und ja allerdings und jetzt kommen wir
zu dem einwand von herrn ulrich bitte
nicht so ungeduldig sein
mein rede paar zielt darauf ab dass wir
hier den rosaroten elefanten auch
benennen der im raum steht man dem denn
so ist wie wir heute festgestellt haben
dass nord stream zwei sehr sehr wichtig
ist für unsere energieversorgung und es
gibt dann die usa oder einige vertreter
der usa die das versuchen zu torpedieren
na dann muss doch in der tat die
bundesregierung sofort auffallen und
sofort sagen nein so geht es nicht
die bundesregierung muss doch hören
greene l klar machen nein so geht es
nicht und dann muss man sagen wenn der
wer sich hier so weiter artikuliert das
moneymoney koffer vor die tür setzt ganz
klare kante die bundesregierung ist hier
in der pflicht schaden vom deutschen
volk abzuwenden
und natürlich auch schaden von europa
und wenn europäische unternehmen oder
deutsche unternehmen hier bedroht werden
er muss sich bundesregierung doch sofort
da vorstellen
denn die usa machen sogar gesetze
exterritoriale gesetze und das erinnert
schon ganz stark an kanonenbootpolitik
das heißt sie wollen ihr handel mit
gezogener waffe führen wenn sie hier
uns was aufzwingen wollen mit
juristischen mitteln exterritorial wie
gesagt und das funktioniert eben nicht
und vielleicht noch mal zur
argumentation er werden immer so zwei
argumente angeführt gastransit durch die
ukraine muss erhalten bleiben werde er
bleibt ja erhalten merkel und putin
haben sich ja so verständigt und dann
gibt es immer noch das andere argument
wir würden abhängig werden vom
russischen erdgas
naja das ist doch lächerlich wir kriegen
einige kubikmeter mehr erdgas aber
umgekehrt wird ein schuh draus
die russen sind doch mehr abhängig von
der finanzierung ihres ihres einkommens
ihres haushaltseinkommens schauen sie
doch mal bitte den staatshaushalt von
russland ich glaube 40 prozent sind das
ist die marke die also russland mit
rohstoff verkaufen dort einnimmt und
dann macht sich doch eher russland
abhängig von uns und nicht umgekehrt
also zieht diese
argument nicht dieses argument ist
einfach nur ein scheinargument und wir
wissen alle was dahinter steckt die usa
wollen einfach nur ihren handel durch
die usa wollen einfach ihre wirtschaft
ankurbeln mit hilfe des dreckigen und
noch dazu überteuerten fracking gases
nichts anderes steckt dahinter
und das eigentlich relativ durchsichtig
aber da sagen wir nein das wollen wir so
nicht und da fordern wir die
bundesregierung auf dem also
entgegenzutreten und man könnte durchaus
ein sprachliches bild anwenden das also
die us-amerikaner sich hier wie im
marktwirtschaftlichen neandertaler
verhalten die also lieber die keule
schwingen als sich in den wettbewerb
zugegeben und auch das lehnen wir ab
und so hat sich die bundesregierung
gesagt na gut dann kann man den euro den
den usa man kann auch mal ein bisschen
entgegen
jawohl in europa darf jetzt mehr
flüssiggas aus den usa adoptiert werden
soll so seien die kontingente werden
vervielfacht die bundesregierung hat
zugestimmt wir unterstützen hier den bau
von flüssiggasterminals und letztendlich
hat die bundesregierung sich sogar in
erbärmlicher art und weise von ihrer
eigenen rechtsauffassung begeben weg
gegeben dass nämlich dieses projekt ein
multi kulti projekt ist von europäischen
staaten aber die eu nichts angeht
und so war denn auch dieses gutachten
des eu-rates dem sich die
bundesregierung vollumfänglich
angeschlossen hat und da kann ich
durchaus zitieren souveränität
die eu verfügt in diesem zusammenhang
über keine
kompetenzen in den ausschließlichen
wirtschaftszonen der mitgliedsstaaten
das war noch stand vom halben jahr
und plötzlich knickt die bundesregierung
ein und das ist erbärmlich und hier
sieht man dass die bundesregierung die
deutschen interessen und auch die
europäischen interessen nicht mehr
grundsätzlich war nimmt und ich fordere
die bundeskanzlerin und die
bundesregierung auf hier ein klares
bekenntnis zu machen und eine klare
kante gegenüber den amerikanern zu
fahren
stehen sie zu diesem projekt stehen sie
zu ihrem amtseid zum wohle des deutschen
volkes handeln vielen dank vielen dank
steffen